The Joe Rogan Experience
the rich world was a population column
from 1945 to 1992
and with the end of the Cold War the
developing world became a column in 1992
until now
the problem is that this is all
temporary because birth rate keeps
dropping people keep living older and
your column eventually inverts into an
open pyramid upside down and now you no
longer have children you no longer have
a replacement generation at all
and there aren't enough people in their
20s and 30s to buy everything and there
aren't enough people in their 40s and
50s to pay for the retirees
so this decade was always going to be
the decade that most of the advanced
world moves into Mass retirement and the
economic model collapses and next decade
was always going to be the decade that
that happened to the developing world
and we found out recently that the
Chinese have jumped the ship and this is
their last decade too
so all of the globalized connections and
consumptions that create the world we
know we are at the end of it and we have
to go back to a world where trade is
more focused on the countries that have
a better demographic and security
infrastructure because the Americans are
no longer patrolling the global oceans
anymore so we're losing the security
ramifications of an open system at the
same time we're losing the demographic
capacity to support it in the first
place and that's all going down right
now
so when you're saying that China has 10
years to go at most what do you mean by
that well we now know that they've lied
about their population statistics and
they're they over counted their
population by over 100 million people
all of whom would have been born since
the one child policy was adopted so this
is one of those places where they've got
more people in their 60s and their 50s
and their 40s and their 30s and their
20s what was the logic behind the one
child was it that they were
overpopulating Mao was concerned that as
the country was modernizing the birth
rate wasn't dropping fast enough and
that the Young Generation was literally
going to eat the country alive so they
went through a Breakneck urbanization
program which destroyed the birth rate
at the same time they penalized anyone
who wanted to have kids and both of
those at the same time have generated
the demographic collapse we're in now
and the problem with that also was that
they wanted male children yeah there's a
cultural aspect to that too and
obviously men can't have kids on their
own
and what is the like ratio to men to
women in the younger people in China now
uh
before the data revision with the last
set of Lies it was about one to 1.2 it
was the most distorted in the world even
more than Sri Lanka where there had been
a civil war for 30 years uh since then
we don't have good sex by sex data but
it's undoubtedly worse
and so what are the other problems that
they're encountering that leads you to
believe that they only have 10 years
left well without young people we've
seen their labor costs increase by a
factor of 14 since the year 2000 so
Mexican labor is now one-third the cost
of Chinese labor their educational
system focuses on memorization over
skills so despite a trillion dollars of
investment in a bottomless supply of
intellectual property theft they really
haven't Advanced technologically in the
last 15 years Mexican labor is probably
about twice as skilled as Chinese labor
now even though it's one-third the cost
they've Consolidated into an ethnic
based paranoid nationalistic cult of
personality and it's very difficult for
the XI Administration to even run it
because it's not an Administration
anymore no one wants to bring G
information on anything so like Putin
lied to his face for example the last
last February about the wars you know
why would I invade Ukraine and you can
see in some of the the presses the the
defense guys in the back of the room
like
I didn't want to say anything because
she has a history of shooting people he
doesn't like
uh and so they the Chinese were the only
country that where it's caught with
their pants down when this all went down
uh the Biden Administration is basically
taking the trade policy of Donald Trump
and running it through grammar checker
and putting it into institutions so we
now have Tech barricades that prevent
the Chinese from buying the equipment
the tools or the software that's
necessary to make semiconductors in fact
he went so far as to say any Americans
working in the sector have to either
quit or give up their American
citizenship every single one of them
either quit or was transferred abroad
within 24 hours so the tech system is
stalled they don't have the young people
to go consumption-led they're completely
dependent on the U.S Navy to access
International Trade they are the most
vulnerable country in the world right
now and based on how things go with
Russia we're looking at a significant
amount of raw materials falling off the
map specifically food and energy
and the Chinese are the world's largest
importer of both of those things so
there's no version of this where China
comes through looking good and the
challenge for the rest of us is to
figure out how do we
in as smooth and quick as a process as
possible figure out how we can get along
without them because they are going away
and they're going away this decade for
certain well if you say they're going
away clearly they're not just going to
lay down no they're going to try to
adjust yeah they'll die
but but how so do you think this is
because like what is other than well
here he would be a big problem right
Taiwan like if if we impose the kind of
sanctions that we've imposed on Russia
if if China decides to invade Taiwan and
the world stands up and the world
imposes sanctions on China how does that
go uh very ugly for the Chinese so you
know say what you will about the Russian
economy it's corrupt it's inefficient
it's not very high value ad but it's a
massive producer and exporter of food
and energy
you put the sanctions that are on the
Russians on Beijing and you get a
de-industrialization collapse and a
famine that kills 500 million people in
under a year and the Chinese know this
they can only push so hard also
you know you can make the argument that
if the Russians succeed they actually
solve or at least address some of their
problems
even if the Chinese were able to capture
Taiwan without firing a shot it doesn't
solve anything for them they're still
food importers they're still dependent
on the United States there's still
energy importers and even if they take
every single one of those semiconductor
Fab facilities intact they don't know
how to operate them because they can't
operate their own and their own are
among the worst in the world not the
best
cool yeah the only reason in my opinion
to be concerned about a Taiwan War
is because she is so isolated himself
that when one person is making all the
decisions and that one person refuses to
access information to make the decisions
strange stuff happens and when you say
refuses to access what do you mean by
that he does not have normal information
flows anymore like even at the height of
the Trump Administration when Trump was
basically isolated himself from the
entire intelligence Community uh he was
still getting the daily briefing there
was still information being put in front
of him but she is so isolated himself he
doesn't want to hear anything except for
what he wants to hear and since no one
knows what the status of the
conversation with the voices in his head
in on any given day no one wants to
bring him anything unless they're
ordered to but how do we know this about
him because there's no one to listen to
anymore that's one of the fun things
about Russia versus China right now is
that the Russian information security is
so poor that American intelligence is
literally listening on everything but in
China we can hear into the office but
there are no conversations happening
what do you mean by that what do you
mean like so no one talks to him about
anything anything if you look at he's
just terrifying to people yeah exactly
because he murders dissidents he murders
anybody that he doesn't murder everyone
but there's a lot of people in prison
and there was also a lot of billionaires
that got disappeared right and any
dissent yeah uh it's you're either
executed or exiled intimidated into
silence there's there's a variety of
options and if you look at the the third
party Congress that we had late last
year that's when they select the polar
Bureau everyone on the politburo now is
a personal flunky there is no one from a
different faction there is no one that
has a history of being incompetent
whoo and what is their plan the Chinese
yeah do we have any idea of what their
plan to get out of this is nationalism
uh if you know that the economic
situation is going to go to pot then you
have a couple of options option one is
you try to cut a deal with a country
that can help you out but the only
country that could do that is the United
States and the sort of strategic
surrender that the Americans would
require is not something that the
Chinese would accept so think about
Germany in 1946 that's the scale of
support and control that the Americans
would cons would insist upon for giving
the Chinese a lease on life uh but if
you go with nationalism give people a
non-economic reason to support the state
so even if you lose your job even if you
can't feed your family I'm Chinese I'm
Han that's enough
that has been the strategy for the last
couple of years will it be enough to
preserve the CCP
too soon to know and they're also in
they're in the middle of the worst
aspect of the pandemic for them ever
yeah now which is very strange for us
because we're on the other end of it
right so what happened over there well
let me start by saying I think it's safe
to say that no country has really
figured out how to handle this well
right uh second I will say there are
seven different variants circulated in
Beijing right now or in China right now
three of them did not exist two or three
months ago and it takes about six months
of data for you to get good information
on the r naught and The lethality so we
just don't know and then third in part
because of G when you're a one-man state
all policy and all authority starts and
stops with you and unless you're
providing very clear guidance on
everything which is impossible for one
person to do for a whole country
especially when the size of China the
bureaucracy either goes into automatic
or does nothing
well right now it's doing nothing so the
data decisions in China are not to
gather data and figure out what we can
do it's to instead of gathering data and
lying about it we're just not going to
gather any data at all
so we're not going to know how bad these
strains are until they get out of China
and circulate in the rest of the world
for six months
so
the lowest fatality estimate that I have
seen that I consider credible is that
they're going to lose a million and a
half people just from covet just from
covet that assumes no broader breakdown
in the health system which we are
already seeing and is this because they
don't have natural immunity because it's
part of it the rigid lockdowns they
encountered yeah you know from from a
plus point of view they did keep the
virus out of the population for almost
three years so no one has natural
immunity but we also know that they're
domestically generated vaccines aren't
great and most of the countries that
used them in order to get the kind of
first batch then moved on to a western
model that worked better so they had a
two-fold problem they did not have
vaccines and they didn't develop natural
immunity and now everyone's getting hit
all at once with a virus that has at
least 50 percent more communicability
than the measles
and their overall health is worse than
ours diabetes as a percentage of the
population is higher they don't have a
critical care system like we have and
their hospitals are really their only
line of defense they don't have a clinic
and a doctor system in the towns like we
do and what about nutrition education
and the understanding of yeah it's
when you industrialize very very quickly
especially in a culture like China where
food is considered a sign of wealth
getting fat is the thing to do so we've
got a lot of diabetes a lot of
hypertension a lot of overweight people
and over two-thirds of the population
lives in the Metro region and their air
quality sucks too so we're kind of
seeing like the worst aspects of the
Indian system in the American system all
in one
so obviously the United States
government is aware of all these things
correct well let's not oversell it but
broadly broadly have you been brought in
to talk to people because you have a
very comprehensive view of this that
includes energy and nitrogen fertilizers
everything like if has anybody ever
brought you in said Can Peter can you
give us an assessment of what what we're
really dealing with sure versus what
each individual expert has to contribute
to it because you're giving an overall
an overall sort of comprehensive view of
this I'm happy to say that I am doing
some work with the defense department I
can't talk about the details obviously
but um I think it's
I think it's good to give credit where
it's due uh one of the many many things
about the war on terror that reshaped
the US government is that we focus all
of our intelligence apparatus on
supporting the troops which is
reasonable so instead of thinking you
know it's 2045 and you're thinking Over
the Horizon who's our foe going to be
and what kind of tank are they going to
use so that we can start preparing which
is what we used to do it instead became
there's someone in on the other side of
this door
and the third floor of this building at
the edge of town in Fallujah what side
of the door are the hinges are because
we need to know if we need to blow it
off the hinges or kick it in
so we focused all on that second thing
for 20 years which meant not only did we
lose all the analysts who knew how to
think forward we lost all the people who
trained them
20 years is a long time so even if
everyone in DOD or the intelligence
Community disagrees with everything I
have to say and
I have some friends I have some
colleagues I have some non-friends who
listen
the fact that they're trying to rebuild
that capacity is a really good sign
and the fact that they started
rebuilding that capacity so soon after
the war and Terror ended means that they
recognized the hole in the system